today the AFC North I have a feeling who
the first overall pick will be the
question is who gets to exercise the
first overall pick Chris you get to if
you answer the trivia question correctly
and here it is
the Bengals obviously have the number
one overall pick this year who was the
last number one overall pick in the
draft to win a Super Bowl ooh that's a
good one there the last number one
overall pick to win a Super Bowl okay
hold on I I really I want to say Peyton
Manning but I'm just waiting on that's
waiting a second here I'm gonna go with
Peyton Manning wah wah wah wait you're
missing here my missing all right Fisher
number one overall pick in 2013 and won
a Super Bowl with the Chiefs just a
couple of months ago but you're thinking
quarterback because it's always a
quarterback who's taken first overall
except when it isn't a quarterback taken
air I think I could have got to Eric
Fisher but of course on TV the pressure
at the moment yeah I could
I couldn't hash it out quite I thought
of this year real quick and I went oh
man there's no number one and just went
right to Peyton Manning dammit the first
overall pick in today's draft a guy who
would be the first overall pick if they
redid the 2018 draft all due respect to
Baker Mayfield and that's Lamar Jackson
the last pick in round 1 the MVP of the
league in 2019 and a guy with a bright
future an unlimited ceiling and he just
keeps getting better and better he's
unstoppable that playoff loss to the
Titans III I'm willing to call it an
aberration because I think once we get
back to football we're gonna see Lamar
Jackson right back where he was and I
don't care how much time defensive
coordinators have to figure out how to
stop him you can't stop him you can draw
it up but you can't stop the guy he is
just physically superior to anybody they
put on the field to try to stop him so
easy one for me Lamar Jackson best
player by far in the AFC North yeah well
he's special you're right I mean he was
the MVP of football and we really
haven't seen anything like him or an
offense built around a guy like him ever
which led to a really awesome special
year and it was
must watch TV with Lamar Jackson so I
can't be mad at you there all right my
second pick or my first pick I'm staying
on the Baltimore Ravens here and I'm
going with Marlon Humphrey there corner
Marlon Humphrey for my money is in the
conversation for the best corner in
football I think he's right there but
Stephon Gilmore Jalen Ramsey he is one
of those guys he is a shutdown island
type corner you know I don't know if
he's become a household name quite yet
there's other stars on that Baltimore
Ravens football team but the Ravens are
a team that puts tremendous pressure on
their there's there's corners and
Humphrey covered the best receivers in
football weekend week out just like a
Stephon Gilmore does and was always as
good as it gets
so for me that would be the second-best
player in the whole division would be
Marlin Humphrey I think he is phenomenal
kind of flying under the radar as far as
being that good big household name quite
yet yeah you're right and and that
Ravens defense very very good one of the
reasons why the Ravens were as good as
they were yes the offense is special and
it's exciting and it's dynamic but the
defense still holding its own even after
plenty of guys left in free agency in
2019 all right for me look this guy may
not have a lot left in the tank but he's
still one of the best players in all of
football he doesn't get the credit he
deserves at this stage of his career
because we haven't seen much of him
lately but Ben Roethlisberger to me is
one of the best players in the AFC North
one of the best players in the AFC one
of the best players in the NFL I'm going
to assume that elbow will be healed and
I'm gonna assume he's gonna be back and
right where he was my one concern with
Ben Roethlisberger is that what happened
last year with the elbow is just the
first body part that is breaking down as
he gets closer and closer to 40 cuz I
don't see him
thriving beyond his 40th birthday the
way Tom Brady and Drew Brees have but
for now still we're looking only at that
division
it's a quarterback driven League Ben
Roethlisberger still a special
quarterback still great things he can do
with the football and if he's healthy
this year the Steelers are gonna be a
factor in that division and in that
conference yeah you know I would expect
them to be healthy I mean I really would
I mean this injury is pretty commonplace
and sports
this day and age and this is a guy
that's a very gifted natural thrower of
the football to where I don't think it's
gonna take much to get him back you know
hitting on all cylinders that way but
I'm with you Mike I mean Big Ben's
special I think in the lures of all-time
football he's a little more underrated
than people you know give him credit for
and I think he's a borderline you know
he's top 10 borderline top 10
quarterback for me in the history of the
sport with what he did you know and he
was special and a lot of years carried
that team with no offensive line and did
all that so I'm not mad at yet for the
Big Ben pick by any stretch of the
imagination ooh there's a lot of good
players in the AFC North there really is
I mean this is where I don't know where
to go but you know what I mean we talked
you said earlier in the show you know
premium is about guys you throw the
football and then guys who can chase
after the guys you throw the football
and the best one in the AFC north of
that is Miles Garrett and he will be my
second pick I mean Miles Garrett you
know I think was you know very close to
on his way to be in that conversation of
leading leading the league in sacks last
year you know before his suspension and
listen I don't like the way he
necessarily handled that whole situation
and all that but the play on the field
is undeniable I mean he's one of the
freakier athletes and all of the sport
he's unbelievable coming around the
edges of pass rusher he has great power
he's a game changer he's a guy that you
got to think about who do I really want
to leave my offensive tackle one-on-one
with this guy you know for 40 drop-back
passes during a football game but you
could see right there I mean those are
special movements and yes I think he is
easily
he was my pick for NFL defensive MVP
last year before the season but I think
he is yes up there with the Khalil max
and von Miller's as the best pass
rushers Chandler Jones and all football
yeah absolutely and you know there was
widespread talk about him potentially
being the Defensive Player of the Year
last year and and it didn't get started
the way that it could have remember he
had those penalties early on right about
that kind of that that reputation did we
kind of forgot he was starting to
develop that reputation is kind of a
rough-and-tumble guy once he went
ultimate rough-and-tumble and ripped off
Mason Rudolph's helmet and hit him over
the head with it but I anticipate that
we won't
be seeing that kind of behavior from
Miles Garrett in the future new coaching
staff again but finally this guy's gonna
reach his ceiling and when he does it's
going to be spectacular another guy
who's getting close to his ceiling
although who knows given his given his
DNA given the fact that his brother JJ
is a three-time Defensive Player of the
Year TJ watt was a contender for
Defensive Player of the Year last year
with his 14 and a half sacks he's a guy
in that classic stealer pass rusher mold
and he's becoming as important to that
defense as Ben Roethlisberger is to the
offense and and they get everybody
together this year and they keep
everybody healthy and the Steelers are a
team that is going to cause trouble for
the teams that we assume are the best
teams in the AFC yeah I mean he's
phenomenal he really is I mean just like
we talked about with Miles Garrett yeah
he's not maybe not quite as athletically
gifted but this is still a guy that's
very gifted in a lot of ways he is and
he can do it all drop back in coverage
plays the run awesome awesome pass
rusher that's yeah he's a great pick by
you there's some players on that
Steelers front seven that probably all
kind of made this is a draft you know
just funny I feel like the AFC North has
a little more star power maybe that the
other two divisions we did so far
compared to the AFC East and NFC East
but you know here my third pick man
there's a lot of good to pick from but
I'm gonna pick my boy you know who my
boy is blue I'm going with Odell Beckham
jr. yes I need another guy he's on I
will he lasted that long on your board
he's gonna be upset he's gonna be upset
he was eager word hopefully he'll let me
still come there and training camp this
year and do more Chris Sims on button
interviews with them but regardless I
mean you have sold out completely you
have already you've only been in this
business for a few years and you have
already abandoned your principles you're
watching what you say all in the sake of
access I am ashamed of you well I'm
picking them third but either way Odell
Beckham jr. even though not a hundred
percent last year we know he other like
the core injury you know and even the
year before not this is still you know
for my money this is one of the most
physically gifted great receivers I've
ever seen in my life and
even that not a hundred percent last
year and the stats not being where they
were Odell Beckham jr. was still a game
changer for the Cleveland Browns
I mean teams still made him priority
number one if it was third down they
were gonna double Odell Beckham jr.
whatever it may be
and I would think this year with the
second year in that you know in the
organization feeling more comfortable
being totally a hundred percent healthy
we're gonna see Odell Beckham jr.
explode this year I'm predicting that
right now I'm predicting Odell Beckham
jr. to be the best receiver in football
once again and reclaim his title that he
had you know two years ago write it down
write it down I'd write it down
see write it down I don't think he's
gonna be the best receiver in football
this year I hope look that they've got
to get over the idea that they we've got
a foursome the football hopefully under
Kevin Stefanski the approach is gonna be
the guy who's open gets the football
period and they got to work with obj to
get him and it looks too fancy had
Stephane digs in Minnesota and he did
for the most part a good job of keeping
Stefon Diggs under wraps when Diggs
wanted the ball more than he was getting
it but you know it was every week last
year what do we got to do to get the
ball Toto Beckham jr. it's like who
cares let's get the ball to the open man
let's get the offense moving let's score
points let's win games that's all that
matters period all right some names that
got left off yeah Matthew Jude on
franchise tagged by the Ravens he
doesn't make it into the draft Nick Shum
who was on track to being the leading
rusher in the NFL last year he doesn't
make it Joe Mixon a guy who's got the
potential to be one of the best running
backs in the NFL he doesn't make it big
trust I really I really wanted to find a
spot for my guy Mark Ingram but how can
you how how can you do it there's a
degree Nancy North AJ Green bud Dupree
you know cam Hayward Marcus Peters at
corner for the Ravens we didn't get to
coleus Campbell who's now in the
division you know he would have might
have been I know I mean that's what's
really interesting about you know hey
you know Fitzpatrick the safety that the
Steelers got last year I mean that's one
of the means the AFC North is you start
to look at it and go man there is really
two we didn't
I didn't drive Gino Atkins he just made
the all-decade team you know I mean
that's to me that hurt my heart you know
this is a drafter where we could add a
legit awesome six rounds there's that
many talented players in the AFC North
right now yeah I mean it really
underscores and I like that we're doing
this we get the idea of where the talent
is and so far through the AFC East the
NFC East and the AFC North the talent is
stocked in the AFC north
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports